you know um
there's uh something that i would like
to talk to you about
i'm just gonna be straightforward and um
remember that time i went out of phil
uh um
we um ended up getting me on a dating
app
oh okay um
how do you think you feel if i had like
a dating app on my phone
yeah i i
we've been knowing that we're getting
separating for a while now you know yeah
but we're not actually yeah i know but
it's almost at this stage you feel like
like roommates of benefits you know um
we are still married
and we're cooking together cleaning
crying arguing sleeping together having
sex that's not roommates with benefits
zinjin saying we're roommates with
benefits it like hurts we're still
married we're husband and wife
and that's like what it is yeah we're in
the process of separation but we are not
actually separated nor divorced yet
have you been talking to people on it
people have reached out to me you know a
ax co-worker messaged me
and said hey do i do i want to meet up
for drinks or whatever
you saw my profile
you know and obviously i it bugs me so i
wanted to like talk to you about it you
know how would you feel if i
if i like
say yeah let's meet up you know nothing
sexual or i don't know you know i mean
you say nothing sexual but it's still at
the end of the day like it is like a
date
but you know this is just a first
meeting nothing goes wrong for me it's
it's not a difference our first meeting
i went home when i went to south africa
for four months see how i can [ __ ]
even still talk to women you can't just
wait until you actually like leave this
house to do all that like but i also
don't know like when do we like finally
separate like when is the when is it i
don't have the answer for that
i am unsure in this relationship like
the longer it's taking us to break up
the more insane
it's not the longest taking this break
up it's the longer it takes you to move
out
[Music]